hoy vengo a hablarles de un tema que a
mí realmente me apasiona
de un tema con el que he llorado he
sufrido pero también he reído he vivido
mis mejores experiencias de vida
les voy a hablar de siete verdades que
ni a ustedes ni a mí nos gusta que nos
digan
pero que son una realidad y que en algún
momento tendremos que enfrentar
y mi primera verdad parte de una
pregunta
cuántos de ustedes han tenido contacto
con una persona con discapacidad
estoy hablando de un contacto consciente
y directo no se vale que simplemente la
hayan ayudado a pasar la calle un día
sino que hayan ido al cine con esa
persona que hayan tomado unas onces con
esa persona
que hayan estudiado que incluso están
trabajando levanten la mano por favor
sin miedo atrévanse
bueno muy bien muchas gracias
tenemos casi la mitad de un público que
hoy nos acompaña que han tenido contacto
con una persona con discapacidad lo que
quiere decir que muy seguramente
ustedes
pueden entender mejor las vidas de estas
personas
y las barreras a las que muchos se
enfrentan para quienes no levantaron la
mano no se sientan mal yo también estuve
ahí alguna vez
la discapacidad era un mundo desconocido
para mí no había tenido contacto nunca
con ninguna persona con discapacidad
y realmente nunca me imaginé que la vida
me llevaría a trabajar en estos temas en
los temas de inclusión para personas con
discapacidad
y esta primera verdad ese no contacto
que muchos de ustedes tienen o no tienen
se debe a una segunda verdad
el desconocimiento
a cuántos de nosotros en los colegios o
en las universidades nos hablan sobre
inclusión sobre garantía de derechos de
los más vulnerables
a muy poco es verdad
ni leyes ni cifras ni convenciones ni
algo tan básico como el lenguaje para
referirnos a estas personas
no son discapacitados son personas con
discapacidad física sensorial cognitiva
múltiple
personas ciegas personas sordas con
sordoceguera
cuántos de ustedes miran a los ojos a
una persona ciega cuando le hablan
oa las personas sordas
muchas veces les hablamos y bien fuerte
cito para que nos pueda escuchar verdad
cuántas veces no les hacemos señas que
ni nosotros mismos entendemos
y esto es conocimiento
muchas veces se da
porque somos indiferentes
somos indiferentes al dolor ajeno y esa
es tal vez la verdad que más nos puede
doler
yo acá voy a hacer una confesión 26 años
de mi vida en los que nunca me percaté
de estar rodeado por alguna persona con
discapacidad en el mundo entero
el 15 por ciento de la población tiene
algún tipo de discapacidad estamos
hablando de casi más de mil millones de
personas en colombia según las cifras
oficiales a 2010 es el 6.4 por ciento de
la población casi tres millones de
personas me atrevería a decir que a
cifras actuales la cifra nacional podría
ser muy equiparable a la cifra mundial
al porcentaje mundial
somos indiferentes y eso no está del
todo mal
la indiferencia es una posición neutral
mi inclinación y rechazo frente a un
tema mientras que usted es el tema no lo
toquen
no los toquen no les afectan y con esa
indiferencia y ese desconocimiento
tal vez sería imposible ponernos en los
zapatos de otros
y esta verdad se las voy a contar a
través de un ejemplo de vida hace cinco
años la discapacidad tocó mi puerta
mi padre sufrió de una trombosis
lo que le
originó a adquirir una discapacidad
física no pudo en ese momento volver a
caminar y tampoco pudo volver a hablar
tuvo un trastorno en el lenguaje
mi padre es médico psiquiatra
amante de la naturaleza un hombre lleno
de vida docente universitario
investigador de casos escritor y esta
situación para él fue muy dura
un hombre muy autónomo que en algún
momento de su vida tuvo que quedar
con una discapacidad física que por
suerte hoy superó hoy en día a mi papá
ya camina lastimosamente no mueve aún
muy bien su brazo
y desafortunadamente
perdió su habla
mi padre hoy en día no puede comunicarse
mi padre era médico psiquiatra docente
para estas personas por su trabajo por
sus experiencias de vida o para él lo
más importante era poder hablar y poder
comunicarse
nunca más lo pudo hacer por fortuna aún
lo tengo a mi lado
y hace pocos años me entregó en el altar
a un hombre maravilloso la discapacidad
puede tocar la puerta de cualquiera en
el momento en que uno menos lo piensa y
solo ahí entendemos las barreras a los
que muchos se enfrentan al principio con
la situación de mi papá descubrí mucho
miedo
yo no sabía cómo ayudarla a sentarse
como ayudar a caminar sé cómo ayudarlo a
comer nos da miedo entrar en contacto
con las personas con discapacidad porque
nos da miedo embarrarla nos da miedo
sentir hacerlo sentir mal
y sobre todo nos da miedo pensar que en
algún momento de la vida tendremos que
enfrentar su situación antes de hablarle
de mis de hablarles de mi última verdad
les quiero hablar de una de las
problemáticas más grandes que tiene este
tema y es el desinterés yo hubiera
podido quedar satisfecha porque mi papá
logró en estos cinco años de fuerte
trabajo
volver a caminar
pero para mí era vital que él pudiera
comunicarse conmigo era vital que un fin
de semana yo pudiera salir con él y
pudiera entender o pudiéramos
comunicarnos para poder entender
qué era lo que quería salir a almorzar
o si quería tomarse un juguito o una
agua a la hora del almuerzo un tintico
estando en el ministerio de tecnologías
en el año 2013 comencé a trabajar en un
área que busca acercar a los ciudadanos
al uso de la tecnología y allí encontré
una emprendedora joven colombiana que
desarrolló un software que le permite a
las personas con discapacidad cognitiva
y algunos trastornos en el lenguaje o
personas que normalmente no pueden
comunicarse hacer el relacionamiento
entre palabras claves e imágenes para
poder comunicarse a expresar lo que
necesitaban yo comencé a utilizar ese
software con mi padre
pero tenía un gran problema mi papá
nunca había tocado un computador
entonces comenzamos en la tarea d
utilizará un computador que hiciera uso
de un computador pero sobre todo que
entendiera el uso del software y le
sacara el mayor provecho para podernos
comunicar estando en el ministerio me
interesé en estos temas como en ningún
otro
porque comencé a vivir en carne y hueso
las bondades de la tecnología
y allí comencé a trabajar en un proyecto
muy interesante llamado cine para todos
cine para todos hace que las personas
con discapacidad visual auditiva y
cognitiva vayan al cine y disfruten de
una película
cómo lo hacen
nosotros al ingreso de una sala de cine
facilitamos unos equipos equipos de
traducción simultánea por los que
escuchamos una vocecita o un audio y
unas tabletas
y gafas inteligentes las personas ciegas
escuchan con ese audio la descripción de
las escenas o lo que va sucediendo en la
película en la cinta cinematográfica las
personas sordas
ven
la interpretación en lengua de señas de
toda la película
recordemos que no todas las personas
sordas leen en español su lengua es la
lengua de señas colombiana
muchos no saben leer en español entonces
era necesario además de los subtítulos
que colocaba mosco locales la
interpretación pero la idea no es
ensuciar la pantalla de la película
porque si nosotros vamos a cine con esas
personas con las personas con
discapacidad visual auditiva o cognitiva
pues la idea es que entre todos podamos
ver la película nosotros como hoy en día
la vemos y las personas con esto las
personas con discapacidad con estos
servicios de accesibilidad y gracias a
la tecnología
cine para todos fue un proyecto que
comenzó a crecer
en el que tuvimos mucho diálogo y mucha
observación e intuición mucho olfato no
solamente en las personas ciegas eran
las únicas que se podían beneficiar de
este proyecto de esta oferta también las
personas sordas las personas con
discapacidad cognitiva comenzamos a
entender a hablar con ellos a saber como
pues a entender cómo hacerlo
en un primer lugar y implementamos esas
gafas pero las personas sordas nos
decían esas gafas son muy pesadas
queremos una solución más sencilla las
tabletas ellos ingresan a la sala de
cine y ponen la tableta en la silla de
adelante
fuimos creciendo
en la cobertura de ciudades por el gran
impacto que estaban teniendo este
proyecto en 2015 llegamos a 9 ciudades a
9 ciudades
entendíamos que esta oferta servía para
poder atender o beneficiar a estos tres
tipos de discapacidad
quiero ponerles un ejemplo para que me
entiendan un poco mejor de lo que les
estoy hablando
quisiera que algunos de ustedes los que
deseen se pongan en los zapatos de una
persona ciega y cierren sus ojos
los que deseen se ponen en los zapatos
de una persona sorda y van a ver con
mucha atención
hacen de cuenta que no escuchan nada nos
vamos a poner en los zapatos de los
otros estamos en una sala de cine y
vamos a ver voy a escuchar un fragmento
de una película
ironman vuela
roza el techo de una edificación
charlize que es lo que se ve por arriba
el edificio central está protegido por
una especie de escudo de energía la
tecnología de estrógeno sobrepasado
todas las bases de ayuda que hemos
capturado productor desciende y tumba a
un soldado y es capaz de montar todo
esto el golpe a otro lanza su martillo y
empuja uno más extiende un brazo y el
martillo vuelve a su mano el ese rubio
de cabello hasta los hombros y usa una
capa roja
natasha lanza una granada contra un
camión salta y le da un codazo a un
soldado
interesante verdad
es así como funciona cine para todos
pero la idea generar un espacio de
inclusión
no un espacio único y exclusivamente
para estas personas sino de inclusión en
el que sus familiares amigos y más
cercanos podamos disfrutar del séptimo
arte al lado de las personas con
discapacidad con cine para todos en el
2016 llegamos a 12 ciudades más
a 12 ciudades en total 3 ciudades más y
rompimos paradigmas
ya las personas con discapacidad no
solamente iban a ver cine ya disfrutar
del séptimo arte sino también hacían
cine con sus celulares
comenzamos a dar talleres en varias
ciudades sobre realización de cine con
celulares temas como planimetría efectos
especiales entre muchos otros temas les
comenzamos a enseñar a las personas con
discapacidad y nos encontramos con unos
productos maravillosos una creatividad
única abrimos una categoría llamada
smart tics incluyente y hoy en día estas
personas participan en esa categoría
demostrando sus grandes habilidades en
la realización de cortometrajes en el
2017 dijimos bueno ya hemos venido
avanzando en este tema hemos tenido muy
buenos resultados pero necesitamos
generar inclusión real
y desarrollamos una aplicación de fácil
uso de fácil acceso
que es única y revolucionaria única en
el mundo única en el mundo porque tiene
los tres servicios de accesibilidad la
audiodescripción el subtitulado especial
y la lengua de señas o la interpretación
en lengua de señas
con esta aplicación lo que pretendemos
es que la industria cinematográfica
comience a usarla para tener en cuenta
un nuevo nicho de mercado que son estos
tres millones de personas a 2010 que no
van solas al cine sino que van en
compañía a sus familiares y amigos
y ahí continúa nuestro trabajo y estamos
tratando de hacer posible que esto
realmente sea incluyente y para cerrar
mi última verdad que espero que no sea
sólo mía sino la de todos ustedes
esto no es cuestión de caridad
mi padre una persona con muchos
conocimientos que aunque haya adquirido
una discapacidad
no deja de tenerlos y de aportar a una
sociedad las personas con discapacidad
visual auditiva y cognitiva que van a
cine pueden pagar una boleta de cine
si la industria piensa en la
accesibilidad de sus contenidos
cinematográficos
y si les abre la oportunidad identifica
que este es un nicho de mercado que en
esos momentos está desatendido
la discapacidad no está en las personas
está en el entorno
y los que somos responsables de volver
accesibles los entornos somos todos
nosotros
creando contenidos educativos accesibles
películas accesibles que la comunicación
que nosotros emitimos a través de las
redes sociales sea accesible y ustedes
quedarán gracias
[Aplausos]